[Music]
in
fast food model news submitted by
dave from atlanta hola town supermodel
gigi hadid got backlash from her fans
i like your reflexes got backlash from
her fans for promoting mcdonald's
what's wrong with mcdonald's what is she
is she like uh
i'm a healthy person like what is she
what is gigi hadid i don't know who she
is like what does she stan does she
stand for
veganism what does she stand for
that would make sense yeah i get your
logic you're another hot person
you gotta know how hot people operate in
the universe hear that
i understand that gigi hadidi like i
if if she was if miss hadidi was like oh
you know you gotta go [ __ ] him meatless
and then all of a sudden she's promoting
mcdonald's it'll make her seem like
but is that what she was doing yeah what
was she doing tell us
people just hate mcdonald's in general
and i got one word for them
[ __ ] didn't mcdonald's come out with a
vegan menu recently
i heard that i think it's a pearls
junior uh introduced the impossible
burger
what vegan nuggets oh yeah you're right
they haven't done a good enough
marketing job on this then if that's
true i guess i follow a lot of vegan
accounts are you vegan no i'm
pescatarian
but i i cook a lot of plant-based at
home
pescatarian sounds like a church group
cause you called it presbyterian
that's funny okay so gigi
she was at coachella it's pretty hot by
the way
well this is what she looks like by the
way oh we know what she looks like
she is very hot she looks part asian or
something she does almost
sometimes when they get too much cheek
fillers people start looking more asian
yeah so she posted this
this photo here that's why you look
hopper
you know what happens like it's like
mother god
damn it dang it sorry what's happening
i'm happy yeah she's half
papa half asian half white yeah because
i kept looking at you and i'm like i
don't want to ask cause i'm not sure
yeah you do look mixed
oh yeah you guys i am all as white as
they [ __ ] come
but how white though are we talking
about what are you
not like the problematic white no irish
were problematic
irish is the drunk and fighting white
you guys are the fun way but they were
also oppressed with like a potato famine
yeah
but yeah no i have definitely had a lot
of cheek filler so yeah excited
yeah are you irish yeah 100 oh
that's where the asian comes angry and
really drunk
yes that's dope it could've been worse
well you guys weren't white like a
hundred years ago so it's okay
there's black irish people but they're
and they're just have black hair
and black features and then they have
really light blue eyes oh gorge
like the guy on grey's anatomy you call
them black irish i guess like they're
black people
yeah like that no they call them black
irish but it's just because they have
like black hair is that like colin
farrell maybe
but he doesn't have blue eyes though if
you look up black deep brown eyes
they're like
light eyes he's asian no he's irish
colin ferrell
just the cheek fillers make him wait yes
oh definition of black irish is used to
describe irish people with dark hair and
dark eyes
thought to be descendants of the spanish
armada of the mid
1500s the dad from the oc is black irish
like black people that live in ireland
just black features
with light eyes so what do you call
ginger's orange eyes black hair
black not like black people features
black black
color brunette like brunettes like a
dark brunette dark
yeah they they use colin farrell's photo
oh okay these are black irish
anyway back to the story yeah why are
they waiting on her so she posted this
and she captioned it pre-festival with
mcdonald's yesterday
fed and hydrated thanks friends you
ain't [ __ ] hydrated from mcdonald's
you're dehydrated from all that [ __ ]
sodium but they're saying like come on
you didn't eat the food there yeah she
did that's the best way to absorb
alcohol you know people think that if
you're skinny or something that you
don't need any junk food
it's like it's okay no it's because
there are a lot of hot people that eat
like trash
growing up i got hella skinny shame like
crazy and
people always be like why don't you just
eat and i'm like yep [ __ ]
i do yeah she eats half a taco for your
information
pretend like she's not getting paid
probably half a million dollars to also
post about this
also eat a fry or two if i was you know
this is french fries
they're the best french fries in the
world in my opinion have you ever had
checkers
checkers rallies checkers and rallies
i'm from the south i got my
south is showing i've seen the i've seen
rallies rallies and checkers has the
best fast food right now period
hand down i trust your judgment because
the south has good food yeah we do
that's true you got big butts you should
trust us with food
i wasn't getting skinny shamed at any
point in my life
but yeah so a lot of people are just
giving her a lot of hate a lot of
backlash
they have to that's just what they hate
on anyone for anything i feel like she
gets hate no matter what
right people want to hate pretty people
why
because they're jealous because they
because they're like women are bad
together they're like mcdonald's is
whatever
are kind of people food you're a hot
people as like a semi-hot person
i get more vitriol from trolley dudes
than other chicks like i think you're
right like women are banding together
right now to like uplift and support
each other but
there's still guys that are like she's
hot enough to follow but i don't want to
like her i don't want to like
follow what she does with her
personality or her lifestyle so any
chance they get to like find a little
they're going to i don't even know it's
because they could never get with
someone like that so they're like oh
take her down
because i feel like she's wrong no
matter what like she posts mcdonald's
like oh yeah right whatever right and
then if she posts like let's say
a protein bar or salad like oh yeah she
would yeah and she's a model
so it's like people don't think models
eat people don't think miles eat
healthily and she could be eating
healthy the whole time and this is the
one time she's like all right i'm just
gonna
go off you're not allowed to be a person
if you're hot in a model yeah
so one comment said the irony of the
sponsorship a delayed april fools maybe
oh god [ __ ] off that's funny mcdonald's
just gets hate no matter what because i
go on their instagram frequently because
we're friends
and then i see the comments that people
leave and then they're just like
so mean why i love i don't know it's
like a kid with a burger or some [ __ ]
and then it's like you know mcdonald's
causes [ __ ] cancer
well and it's crazy because it's [ __ ]
mcdonald's like like it's not a person
like why are you
like it's so weird it's so weird to me
because they're trying to [ __ ]
whistleblow
something that doesn't even exist yeah
like this other comment says i really
don't understand
why you would promote mcdonald's in fact
it utterly baffles me why an
intelligent well-informed and
influential person like yourself
would want to be or would what
what what would what to want to be okay
want to be affiliated with such a
company
surely it can't be for the money there
are so many other ways to be
fed and hydrated well what is mcdonald's
done something like chick-fil-a
where they're anti-like lgbtq or
anything it's just number one
they're just well i mean they make a lot
of money
like walmart does so any company that
makes a ton of money
and and it's it's huge they're gonna
have its problems corporate normal
problems yeah right maybe they're
blaming
a lot of it of like obesity on
mcdonald's and that's what so maybe
they're just fat phobic and they should
check themselves and
mcdonald's owns a lot of real estate
like they own a lot of like uh
land for growing all the potatoes and
all that [ __ ] and
cows and and like the factory farming
and all of that stuff
so there's a lot of that that being said
i did book a mcdonald's commercial back
in like 2014 i made a hell of money from
that
thanks i don't know it was for the latin
market what the [ __ ] mcdonald's there's
a [ __ ] latina here and right here
no you should have came out sooner
that's all right i don't understand why
people
can hate a hamburger so much
like it's the nazi party well it's like
if it's not for you then just
move it on i've never hated a piece of
food
to the point where it outraged me then
you've never been a woman to my right
ladies
like sometimes i think the media will
shame women into like
that's why when you know like some white
girls their whole personality is liking
pizza because it's like rebellious and
outrageous
oh is that what it's all about i thought
they just love pizza no no no it's like
it's like a
statement against the man yeah like what
man is telling you not to eat pizza
the media yeah the meat well [ __ ] the
media
yeah the man is like uh you know as a
whole [ __ ] the man
like big brother yeah yeah okay okay
okay big brother all right yes like big
brother
it's like you know you're supposed to be
look a certain way
eat a type of way oh i see four let's be
honest the male gaze
yeah and so if you're like rebellious by
eating mcdonald's let the girl eat some
[ __ ] fish
you know what's crazy because i think
guys would love a girl that would just
pound a pizza down you know but still be
skinny yep but still be skinny
yes not me yeah you like a thick bridge
my girlfriend's ass
is nice and fat she's not thick yeah
she's very fit but i do find
thick women attractive too because they
got nice titties and stuff
but when i when i'm not talking about
like if they look like brother is you
know
or like job of the hood that's different
yeah that's different right but then
like
i think do you know the hawaiian man
that sings somewhere over the rainbow
yes yeah i think he's native hawaiian
it's okay what about it though i gotta
correct her on the tree i guess
because i love brother is and i may i
use him as a reference but
like as an attractive woman even though
he is a male i know there are women that
look like him sometimes you know what
i'm saying that's just not your flavor
it is not my flavor of ice cream yeah
this is my opinion okay i think guys
are much more forgiving when it comes to
what a woman looks like and what is a
i've never heard that then females are
of themselves and females are of each
other said two men
no i think yeah no i think girls worst
enemy is themselves
first before society before men it's
because we're all trained to look a
certain way and so like
like we shame each other it's like when
you you're all oppressed but like i'm
playing by the rules so she has to play
by the rules too
like look at her but who's creating the
standards is it men that's what i'm
saying because i don't know
i don't know any man that goes she's not
pretty enough no
but the standards of beauty for guys is
probably here
where girls is up here no men were the
ones that cause all the dudes that i
know
well that's a little bit different too
because most men don't find
runway models and print models
attractive it's okay think about who's
in entertainment
and who's casting entertainment so who's
getting cast as the lead roles and
actresses
well they cast a certain look and that
that look is skinny
and like you know yeah exactly and
attractive and that sets the standard
for all of across
all of media because that's what little
girls are watching when they watch
a tv show or they watch a movie and like
mostly it's dominated by males
but it's they're successful because both
genders are supporting
this not because it's like okay so when
i was growing up there weren't a lot of
like brown
people in tv shows and i thought oh i
can't be an actress because like there's
no one that looks like me on tv
because that's what i thought and then
also i've met people
like um i have friends that were casting
a certain way or they only had a certain
look in their mind because those are the
shows that they watched growing up and
it was all white
right and they didn't even think like oh
i should cast like more ethnicities
right and then
so i feel like the change has to be made
first by
the people on top like casting like
normal looking people like like more of
a
you know national average type of body
for me like this is okay
to be a lead woman um and then then
everybody follows it's on the same token
where it's like where if you feel like
as a woman
it starts up here then and the same
argument i feel like we're in the same
shoes right when we first started off in
entertainment
there were no asians in media yeah yeah
so there's no agents in media people
pulling the streams up here aren't
putting asians and rules so asians
the generals so everyone accepts like
asians shouldn't be lead role exactly
but the thing is i feel like where i
feel like it still starts from you
because me and joe never ever thought
that
we were like there's no asians in the
media that's perfect time for us to come
out and be the first asian media
men get told that they can do anything i
also thought it was tied to
money and popularity right so people are
choosing a certain look because people
will buy that it is but they buy the
look because they're used to that look
right but who is buying it is we gotta
figure out who's at the top i know
so that's that's what i'm saying is like
okay if it
is a male conspiracy right i
have never really encountered and all
throughout my
life men have way lower standards
to what they find attractive in women
than when i see women
having if you could get any woman in the
world to suck your dick right
you would pick these right girls to suck
your dick and then they're
they're ready ready and willing to suck
your dick to be in that movie
right but then but but i don't know i
know who you want i know my standard
cream of the crop like i know my i know
that's well that's because they look the
way they do i mean it's you don't have
to be
male or female to look at gigi hadid and
go wow
symmetry wow beauty right like and i
think
there's some form even dogs probably
like her dogs
so let me get to my point let me get get
to my point okay so
like all across culture there is a
different standard of
beauty right so but there is that one
rule the hourglass rule of
in in different eras too women might
have been chunkier when women might have
been
right yeah yeah so then a lot of it does
have to do with it like these
are in right now that's the only thing
they've done
right but in the 90s it was big boobs
and flat butt right and then and they're
more
right right your titties are in thank
god
i think generally don't worry your time
will come okay thank you
this is a blanket statement but i think
guys are
less critical when it comes to what they
think
is okay and not okay so for example all
of
all of your boyfriends right probably
don't see the issues that you see
in your face and say you're just [ __ ]
beautiful and perfect it's true what
what's
what's going on i don't see it and then
they feel bad because that's because
they love us
no but they already know they already
saw that the first day they met because
if you were constantly being told what
to be then you would know what to
constantly look for so if you're like oh
that girl's got it down that girl
doesn't have it down
like but you're that's what i'm saying
but that's my point you're being
critical of other women and yourself
yeah where the guys are looking at you
and saying
she's hot already i want to be i want to
be with you it's very true right but
we've been trained from a very young age
yes yeah but yeah i guess my point is
like i don't know
who's rolling yes yes i don't know is it
men
like are there a group of men out there
i don't know it's usually the
people with money that advertising
exactly because you might be right
you're the models who are in the produce
yeah they're producing so that becomes
the standard yeah because that's what
all of us see
in the media that's what all everyone
sees but it looks like shit's changing
i like that because i always liked
thicker girls but they weren't just for
the record he likes
thicker girls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you